bien en este mínimo global en un
sistema global de este mínimo tú
basa el primer ep lario e en dos pilaris
establece que la mayor
multinacionales medio ambiente rehn pay
y en el pais no aguanta no tiene poder
comercializar una parte del mercado en o
solo en el pais donde nella
residencia fiscal los segundos pilares que
habrá uno en este mínimo que tenga sitio y
sitio estable que nesta compra que tiene que
kin invernaderos 3 por ciento de especias y
araña imponer a la multinacional que
operan en el territorio sau che tenga
a la residencia fiscal en nuestro
país que hablo tanto genial
plan multinacional podrá ejercer
zlatan do su residencia fiscal a un país
que tiene una acción de tributo de bayas a
país que tiende a tributar menos naciones
del rey por ciento y quien sabe si querer
pagar en el lugar en las laderas
Orígenes históricos, veo que hago clic en eso.
multinacional desolladora a beneficio
sin tributa nene su espías non dello
sorin aaron chetan fases los excluyo
implementar una reforma fiscal galloway
por ejemplo, posible homogeneidad del sistema
impuestos internacionales
ss locativo de halles kubrick fue
un proceso morabítico de las lecciones de
biden y con mantener un si eres de
país loris y siempre es antonio a provavo
una marca inclusiva parece estar en esto
minimo global y la hoja tambien
energías mente si abro parte de la
ministro de hacienda en via vario
problema era
solo el primer paso
porque la especia necesita implementar
legislación nacional
esto y en incómodos intercambios entre países
landa hungría o estonia sostuve tener
impuesto menos de parentesco aunque un centenar y debe
compromiso si el compromiso debe nora
implementar en las clases en la selección nacional
es inmediatamente importante
especialmente hablando en europeo porque
debe ser un director
europeo de la comisión europea y si
celebrará la tan esperada unanimidad de tres países
han liquidado a cambio de las cargas en
sí mismo por ciento o demasiado como era
inmediatamente propone en 21 argentina y otros
país como kenia nigeria dama casali
aaron del acuerdo de borgers propone en
esto superior al 30 por ciento no es
el resultado del sitio de una negociación es
solo el primer lugar seguramente lo sabe
siempre grandes sas se encontrarán en cualquier
camino del rey de sir en sim pronto
espero que en un primer airbus sea tal
paso por mi aprender el multi lari muchos
lado el presidente biden caro
más pronto en esto que más pronto entonces
aumentar la regulación excitada
inmediatamente en la serie a fue inmediatamente grave al
país, pero se benefició de
esta nueva entrada y expresó
la union europea si y sobre todo
Francia durante su presidencia
comienza en hora negra del smi el 22 e
será responsable de la implementación de un
A nivel europeo se pone en forma en verano
tanto ea protegerá para para se
forma rápida y áspera